[Música]
y llegamos a brasil para hablar con
nuestra corresponsal a valeria sacones
de la operación policial contra
narcotraficantes que dejó 22 muertos en
una favela de río de janeiro valeria la
salud muy buena mañana porque hay
acusaciones de genocidio tras estas
operaciones
bueno la última hora dice que los
muertos lamentablemente ya estuvieron a
24 y hay 5 heridos graves y la acusación
es por lo siguiente en los últimos años
la policía ha estado presente en diez de
las grandes en 10 de las 13 masacres que
se perpetúan en las favelas de río de
janeiro en este caso la policía ha
alegado que estaba preparando la
operación desde hace meses porque estaba
detrás de toca un gran narcotraficante
de la zona norte de la ciudad que sería
responsable junto a su facción el
comando vermelho comando rojo del 80% de
los tiroteos en ríos pero el ministerio
público federal varios diputados de la
oposición de la izquierda y también ongs
se quejan de que en esas operaciones
siempre los muertos son negros
ciudadanos negros jóvenes de baja renta
el 86% de los muertos a mano de la
policía en río son negros cuando este
grupo representa tan sólo el 51 por
ciento de la población entonces lo que
se preguntan muchas personas de la
oposición y de la sociedad y si esta
operación sería aceptada en un barrio
rico como copacabana como ipanema con
mucho turismo con una renta muy alta al
mismo tiempo que también hay una parte
de la población que se dice cansada de
la violencia y que pide cada vez más
mano dura a pesar de que esas
operaciones se perpetúan el año tras
años y no vemos que resuelven un
problema que es básicamente la ausencia
de estado en grandes partes de las
ciudades y el control de grupos
criminales que muchas veces luchar entre
sí claro valeria es que también hay un
largo historial de operaciones que dejan
sangrientos saldos sin río de janeiro
exactamente hace un año precisamente en
mayo del año pasado hubo una operación
parecida en una favela cercana llamada
jacarezinho que se saldó con 28 muertos
y fue famosa en todo el mundo porque las
naciones unidas llegaron a pedir una
investigación independiente sin embargo
estas investigaciones
pero nunca llegan a ningún lugar y lo
que vemos en brasil es una guerra de
narrativas parecida a una guerra como
puede ser en ucrania porque la policía
siempre dice que actúa porque fue
atacada en cambio los habitantes de las
favelas dicen que no que llegan
disparando luego también la policía dice
que no que lo que hay una cierta
connivencia entre los habitantes de las
favelas y los narcotraficantes entonces
es muy difícil saber dónde está la
verdad cada vez hay más evidencias
gracias a que los habitantes de las
favelas tienen teléfonos móviles y
pueden mostrar casi en directo muchas
veces incluso en directo lo que está
pasando pero esas pericias técnicas de
recoger las balas de analizar de dónde
vienen los tiros son realizadas pero
nunca se sabe a ciencia cierta porque
nunca hay una conclusión
y finalmente hay mucha impunidad hay un
proyecto que ya fue parcialmente
implantado en san paolo de colocar
cámaras
los uniformes de la policía para que se
pueda determinar qué acontece pero por
razones internas todavía no se ha
llegado a este punto también hay un
histórico en otras operaciones en que se
ha demostrado que la policía ha cambiado
las pruebas ha movido cuerpos ha
retirado
balas ha colocado armas en las manos de
las víctimas entonces esto también
empaña un poco la credibilidad de la
policía